[Musik]
herzlich willkommen ja auch das heutige
gespräch freue ich mich ganz besonders
mein gast ist 86 jahre alt ein
großmeister der literatur ein politisch
engagierter intellektueller ein
liebhaber japans und jemand der sich
gerne mit der höchsten aller künste
beschäftigt nämlich mit der kunst zu
leben
herzlich willkommen adolf muschg ja sie
werden bald 87 jahre auf wenn sie auf
ihr langes und reiches leben
zurückblicken war das ein gutes leben
interessant dass sie sagen zurückblicken
es ist komischerweise nicht so dass ich
das gefühl von länge haben habe sondern
von unterschiedlicher präsenz in der
zeit ne also je älter ich werde desto
das ist keine neuigkeit desto klarer
oder transparenter scheint mir die
kindheit und sie wird auch wichtiger
weil da die mosaiksteine gelegt wurden
sozusagen mein spielzeug mit dem ich
mich ein leben lang beschäftigt habe
natürlich auch das was mir gefehlt hat
und dann kommt die zeit geht zeitgefühl
geht im rückblick entspringen es gibt
hochintensive perioden die ich in
erinnerung habe fast minute zu minute
sowie in der klarheit von träumen und
andere reinelt nicht wenn ich sage nur
der wüsten aber jedenfalls sind sie
nicht beschrieben sind es und bevor wir
von lebenskunst reden was ja nach
schiller die schwierigste und größte der
künste ist die kunst beschäftigt sich
eigentlich genau mit diesen
zusammenhängen nach meiner fahren
nämlich damit dass die zeit ungleich ist
in der für uns selbst in der wir leben
und auch dass die historische zeit von
katastrophen wie krieg und kriegsende
das war ein glück
abgesehen die übrige zeit keine rolle
spielt oder fast keine sondern man ist
ein darstellerin verschiedenen szenerien
und die szenerien werden weniger wichtig
im alter und mehr wichtiger wird das was
man daraus gemacht hat oder was einen
davon geblieben ist das gedächtnis ist
hoch selektiv natürliche sache und
betrüger es versucht zu schummeln
sonst braucht man keine psychoanalyse
aber ein langes leben wenn ich mich gut
fühle habe ich das gefühl überhaupt
nicht
ich bin einfach da noch auf ein langes
leben wobei die zahl von der zahl her
gesehen nur zu recht haben ich bin der
älteste meiner familie und war
eigentlich in meinen sogenannten besten
jahren vor allem als hypochonder
bekannter ist das ein gutes mittel den
wald zu werden über das werden wir noch
reden über die hypochondrie jetzt wenn
sie sagen ihr leben kommt ihnen gar
nicht lang vor im rückblick sind aber
diese einzelnen augenblicke diese
zeitlosen momente vielleicht diese
augenblicke die außerhalb der zeit sind
und sich irgendwie eingebrannt haben
besteht darin ein gutes leben aus der
aneinanderreihung oder der summe solcher
zeitloser momente ich glaube das gute
leben besteht darin das ist jetzt
missverständlich was ich sage aber dass
das interesse an einem selbst nicht
aufhört nicht erlischt nicht schwächer
wird und dass die frage warum habe ich
mich damals so verhalten und darum habe
ich mir das entgehen lassen
oder warum habe ich das nicht gesehen im
alter drängender wird also interessanter
wird ich beginne mich eigentlich erst
jetzt richtig für das zu interessieren
was da in mir und mit mir passiert ist
das ist nicht furchtbar viel
weltgeschichte ich gesehen aber es
natürlich alles für mich
lebensgeschichtlich gesehen und ich habe
vor fremden schildert zitiert das
lebenskunst die größte aller künste ist
aber leben selbst kommt mir also um eine
unglaubliche kunst vor auch evolutionär
gesehen also werk ist auf die idee
gekommen dass materie anfängt sich zu
organisieren bis hinauf zum oder hinab
bis zum individuum so viel wir wissen
gibt das sonst nicht irgendwo im
universum
aber was wissen wir über das universum
was weiß dieser staub locker für das was
evolutionär an anderen orten möglich
gewesen ist und diese disparität
ziemlich dazwischen dass wir eine
geradezu quantitativ lächerliche einheit
des universums sinkt und andererseits sv
und die ganze welt ist und wenn du live
spielen ist alles verspielt das lernt
belehrt einen auch sozusagen oder man
fern während das quantitative denken
denn das führt zu nichts so gar nichts
sondern da seine pflicht und wels einen
augenblick heißt dem faust und es ist
nur im augenblick da und lebenskunst ja
was ist das entscheidende und der kunst
die einsicht in ihre begrenztheit grenze
ist in der kunst vorn
es gibt keinen grenzenlosen rembrandt er
hat einen rahmen und darin gibt es nur
bis ins kleinste hinein in einem gesicht
die wir noch nie gesehen haben und ich
verstehe das ist das ungeheizte paradox
so leute an den ich mich ein bisschen
orientieren gelernt haben wieder alte
goethe wusste das was ist das das
besondere der einzelne fall was ist das
allgemein der einzelnen fall das ist das
besondere millionen fälle
da hat die statistik plötzlich
ausgedient das ist finde ich interessant
also diese diese grenze die beide kunst
da ist die den einem kunstwerk eine form
gibt ja was würden sie sagen kann man
auch übertragen auf unser leben ab so
dass wir sozusagen die grenze
akzeptieren müssen und sie uns erst
unserem leben er ist eine form gibt was
sind das für vier grenzen diese hätten
menschlichen leben
da tut erst durch das leben leben wir
die kunst das leben recht zu brauchen
heißt sie also ich weiß nicht mehr genau
und es ist keine kein wunder glaube ich
dass diese grenze auch ärgerlich und zu
hoch angstbesetzt ist ich habe viele
große kollegen kann e wie zum beispiel
das inntal skandal behandelt hat wie
kommt die schöpfung darauf mich
abzulöschen wenn sie mich schon an zu
ende
und dieses gefühl habe ich weniger ich
verstehe plötzlich warum in der antike
die philosophen gehabt da gesagt haben
einige die station lebenskunst zeigt
sich als kunst des sterbens
ich würde es ein bisschen weniger
deutlich sagen zeigt sich in der kunst
des lasten des lassen und günstig unter
lassen dürfen
ich muss nicht jede heads mitmachen
immer eine der allergien die ich am
fernsehen haben gegen der schweizerische
besonders weil da die reklame immer
weiter geht nämlich bis mit danach in
deutschland hört sie wenigstens 20 uhr
auf dem zdf
da kommt mir das vor wie eine sünde an
einen mir wichtigen mächtigen botschaft
die gerade transportiert produkte sind
krimi war oder eine sendung wie unsere
jetzt und plötzlich quasselt einer rein
und erklärt in einer hysterischen
mundart stimme was für eine gelegenheit
die ich da gerade verpasst
und ich kann ihnen sagen ich habe im
alter eine allergie gegen
klamm entwicklung die ich mir nicht
zugetraut hätte denn mein erstes buch
handelt von einem reklame berater und
das fand es war damals in die 60er
jahren noch eine nachricht der neuen
zeit sagen
ebenso hat das hasenjahr erstes buch
spielt in japan ein land das für sie
ganz wichtig ist aber diese diese
abneigung gegen die reklame
da kommt natürlich wieder die geht der
gesellschaftskritiker muss zum vorschein
überrascht mich jetzt warum das erst im
alter also primär ist brisant wird man
hat es hat ja früher bilde ich mir ein
auch ein bisschen witzigeren klammen
gegeben aber für alte leute sind das was
früher war spannender gewesen
die figur dessen der das bewusstsein
steuert war irgendwo eine faszinierende
figur weil das selbe ja auch eine
politik passiert weil man wenn man über
reklame über bedürfnisse rät natürlich
etwas über ganz elementares redet und
diese bedürfnisse zu steuern und so zu
besetzen mit objekten mit einer
botschaft
das ist nicht nur die treuherzige auf
einmal tine reklame der 20er jahre
sondern das ist eine manipulation eine
gezielte wo der andere dadurch pfiffig
sein bilder reklame mensch dass er mir
pfiffigkeit unterstellt dass wir beide
unsere reklame genießen und ich sein
produkt kaufe und plötzlich mir diese
art von instrumentalisierung meine
bedürfnisse ist mir 'ich möchte was
sagen des teufels geworden weil ich viel
natürlich kunst dann ja das ist
natürlich auch eine kränkung und eine
beschränkung der eigenen freiheit die
man vielleicht angst da dass man mal
ignoriert wird beeinflusst wird
aber das ganze leben besteht ja ich habe
es beeinflusst würde ich mal sagen und
man kann ja nicht grundsätzlich sind
etwas gegen verfügung haben unser ganzes
liebesleben besteht daraus nicht aber
die verführung zur ware
und ich glaube dass die allergie kommt
auch mit dem bewusstsein in welchem
grade wir uns beim konsumieren damit
kommen wir aus thema vom lassen zurück
lassen damen müssen den genuss des
weniger tuns weniger macht uns weniger
handelszeit gewinn was immer schon das
wort gewinn ist falsch sondern die zeit
auf sich wirken lassen
das ist ja gerade jetzt ein sind wir
einander um gehören testperiode denn wir
werden von vielen abgeschnitten was man
normalität nancy und was mir deutlich
wird aber da bin ich zum glück nicht der
einzige auch ganz jungen wird es
deutlich muss gar nicht von greta ist
dass wir so nicht weitermachen können
dass grenzenlosigkeit nicht eine
lebensform des menschen ist
und damit sind wir irgendwo wieder bei
der lebenskunst das grenze ich rege mich
vom sterben wie wir dann das anstellen
oder wie wir uns dabei anstellen ist
eine frage die man sich eigentlich
ausstellen kann wenn sie aktuell wird
und dann hat man wichtig ist aber auch
diese grenze versuchen ja einige eher
leute abzuschaffen direkten valley einen
den tod zu überwinden auf langlebigkeit
hinzugehen
sie selbst haben gesagt diese
auseinandersetzung mit den eigenen
grenzen mit dem tod ist ganz zentral für
ein gutes gelingen das leben und sind
vor vier jahren sind sie wieder in die
protestantische kirche eingetreten hat
das auch mit marisa auseinandersetzung
mit dem tod zu tun ich glaube nicht an
ein leben nach dem tode
wenn man mir das glaubensbekenntnis vor
sagen würde ich fragen welchen satz ich
da mit welcher absicht damit anfangen
könnte würde ich sagen bin mit keinem
ich glaube nicht an ein leiblicher
verstimmung auch nicht meinem eigenen
fall
ich glaube in einen ganz bestimmten sinn
auch nicht an das berühmte
ostergeschehen in theologischen sinn
aber ich habe ein seit der jugend
schwieriges aber intensives verhältnis
zu dieser gestalt jesu der voller
widersprüche ist und im grunde das
produkt eines speziellen ist ischen
konstrukt ein gott der söhne gibt es nur
bei den griechen und die juden die
orthodoxen juden haben ja auch dass die
eigentliche lästerung betrachtet ist
lang auch als problem darf als prophet
darf jesus so scheinen im islam aber als
gottes sohn
da ist eine so ist eine so unmenschliche
einen abgrund zu überspringen zur
vernunft sagt diese paradox geht an die
grenzen der vernunft stößt man da ja
aber seltsame wieder mensch ist wenn er
das wort vater hört aber mann oder frau
ist dann wird etwas archetyp ist in
einem bach dass ich nach heimkehr
sicherheit einkehr was immer sehnt licht
als das was ich von meinem persönlichen
vater vater meinem eigenen vater
mitgekriegt aber nicht von ihm erlebt
habe er war ein kleinbürgerlicher
kleinbäuerlicher müsste ich besser sagen
christ mit einem tollen pietistischen
hintergrund also ich habe in erziehung
gehabt wie man sie heute nur noch in
stünde laut kreisen erwarten kann und
ich bin ja natürlich nicht davon ausgehe
richten so gut ich konnte aber ich habe
erlebt eines tages gab es diesen vater
nicht mehr ich erinnere mich und den
ersten schultag deutlichen
schulkameraden neben mir und sagte du
hast paranal der vater der leipzig und
über raum und ich weiß noch wie der
blick 262 hier geboren worden
er war 62 80 geboren
das war also am ersten schultag schon
hinter maze und 70
und da habe ich da blitzt er mich doch
fuhr zeigte mir eine urangst an diesen
vater werde ich nicht lange haben und da
war im grunde schon ein bisschen ein
gespenst und was er sagt was er mich zu
wehren versuchte vor allem wenn wir
zusagen zur kirche gingen hat ja auch
etwas gespenstisches erlebte es nicht in
form von güte sondern in sinn von
strenge gegen sich er könnte sich
verdammt wenig er hat es selbst wenn
humor und sprachwitz dann habe ich nicht
gestohlen denn hat da haben auch meine
anderen halbgeschwister dieselben wasser
haben geerbt aber überzeugen dass mensch
war er leider keinen augenblick
vielleicht in den letzten wo ich ihn
besuchen durfte nach der schule ging ich
ins krankenhaus neumünster im zuckerberg
und da konnte eigentlich schon fast
nicht mehr regnen
abra gab mir seine wahl war nicht krenz
um das ja die dürfte er nicht essen aber
ließe sich doch immer weichen weil er
wusste ich musste ihn besuchen und wir
saßen einander ziemlich sturm gegenüber
beide wussten was los war allen
bereichen konnte es nicht sagen
der mann stand der satz vom guten hirten
also da war ich gehe weiter mich unter
den level oder was immer und ich
bestanden weil auf diesen satz und
wussten dass wir eigentlich einander
nichts zu sagen hat ich hatte angst vor
jedem wort und dieses diese können durch
die verliehen
das war meine abends markt im grunde
haben wir in einer gabe abschied
genommen die in mir nach werk denn nicht
dort war zollikon durch geboren bin war
wäre war einmal ein weltzentrum der
wiedertäufer
amerikanischen arms und die
niederländischen wieder teufel und so
weiter
die hatten alle eine wurzel in zollikon
man es auch davon zwei in der limmat
ertränkt wurde und ich habe das alles
noch mitbekommen ich dem buch unser
zollikon in dem das alles breit
geschrieben
das hatte nichts mit soli cohen im krieg
zu tun dass ich kannte aber sehr viel
mit meinem vater und sie haben mich
ausführlich befragt warum kehren sie
darum dahin zurück ich kehre auch darum
zurück das klingt ungemein abstrakt um
mich mit meinem vater weit zu
unterhalten soll in nächster zeit immer
noch gegeben ist und insofern am leben
zu erhalten denn ich er hat von mir
nichts gehabt und ich von ihm auch
nichts
ich weiß doch wer gelitten hatte und
dass wenn die leute mich fragen sowohl
blick auf schmidt groß babbel spazieren
und zugleich war es ja eine große scham
für ihn er hat mich auch nicht in der
kirche taufen lassen sondern hörten ein
haus kaufen aber die feinste die pfarrer
oskar faller dann nachher zum
grossmünster kam also diese mischung von
erwählt sein und nicht genügend die
verbindet sich auf allen ebenen für mich
mit meinem vater hermus gewissens mal
ein rares zeitdokumenten es gibt nämlich
einen dokumentarfilm über sie der wird
im september am zürcher filmfestival
premiere feiern adolf muschg der andere
heißt der film von erich schmid und
darin kommt auch eine kurze szene vorbei
wo man ihren vater sieht und auch ihre
mutter will lernen.de mal gemeinsam an
[Musik]
ja das sieht man diesen streng
pietistischen vater aber ein amish sein
so sehe ich auch ein orthodoxer jude
also nicht wahr und die mutter spielt ja
auch eine interessante rolle in ihrer
biografie und erziehung an der vater
stirbt dann als sie 13 jahre alt sind an
darmkrebs und die mutter war depressiv
phasenweise war krankenschwester und
auch ihre hypochondrie die sie erwähnt
haben leitet sich vermutlich aus ihrer
interpretation von der von der mutter ab
weil sie sie gepflegt hat einer
krankenschwester gelernte und hat ihren
beruf nicht ausgeübt das heißt sie war
noch klägerin schülerinnen und nachher
war sie privatklägerin sie hatte angst
vor dem spital und von der verantwortung
und ich war das was sie gut machen
wollte und richtig machen wollte und am
meisten hatte sich dann mit mir zu tun
und am kompetentesten fühlte sie sich
wenn ich krank war
also war das eigentlich ein ähnliches
ziel krank zu sein
und dann durfte sie mich hüten und so
weiter und pflegen bis ich gesund waren
und ich musste immer noch zwei tage
länger im bett bleiben wenn ich mein das
fieber vorbei war und sie selber ist
dann in einem entscheidenden punkt
meines lebens krank schwer depressiv
geworden mit allem schrecken was
dazugehört also folglich das war das
hallo letzte gewesen sie brachte es
fertig in der epischen anstalt eine
absonderung haus zu finden indem sie
nicht geradezu als illegal und mein
vater starb in dieser zeit und sie hat
ihnen eigentlich nicht mehr besuchen
dürfen und dass
damals hat man sich noch zeit genommen
für seine krankheiten
sie war eigentlich zweieinhalb jahre
krank und die ursachen banal gesprochen
waren religiös eingeredet von einer
frommen nachbarin was frau mischt sie
haben ihre mutter kreieren lassen also
meine großmutter ihre mutter wissen sie
dass sie dann nicht in den himmel kommt
und meine mutter hat dieses gewicht
benutzt um sich fallen zu lassen
also sie war schuld an der ewigen
seligkeit ihrer mutter man muss sich das
heute vorstellen wo in welchen milieus
ist so eine erklärung noch denkbar
aber es war auch bei ihr vor geschützt
denn viel viel später habe ich erfahren
was sie immer verschwiegen hat dass sie
ein missbrauchtes kind war ihres eigenen
vaters
das ist einmal zum vorschein gekommen
und ich hüte mich eigentlich dabei zu
verteilen weil netz das falsche aha dass
wir heute bei unserer kanzlerin kalter
für solche fälle reservieren
der schlimme vater dann hat man dann
erklär und dann weiß man alles mann war
es nicht ich weiß sogar meine mutter
ganz wenig ich weiß dass sie gerne warm
zu mir gewesen wäre
ich habe ich weiß vor allem dass sie
unbedingt wollte dass ich gelinge das
mein leben gelingt und in ihren augen
gelangen ist wenn man professor ist das
war das höchste der gefühle
also auch da wieder diese großen
erwartungen nicht mehr vom vater soll
auch von der mutter und das klima der
angst der schuldhaft ich kite wie löst
man sich von so einer vergangenheit und
wie wichtig ist es auch im alter noch
irgendwie immer wieder daran anzuknüpfen
um sich selbst zu verstehen
es würde für mich zur heiligen pflicht
als halbwüchsiger zu lügen
denn nicht durch meinen wahren probleme
meiner mutter nicht sagen
das plausibel und einigen gründen hätte
dass ihre sicherungen gesprengt weil es
fürchtete ich es ich durfte aber nicht
mal eine freundin hatte durch ist ja
nicht sagen
er hat ja dann erst einmal aber das war
nur die eine seite meiner mutter sie
hatte eine andere die sich verkörperte
in ihrem bruder und eine war in london
hätte swiss national tourist office im
krieg und hat während dem blitz hat den
london und dem bombardierten london um
schweizer panoramen in der untergrund an
die wand der u-bahn projiziert und hat
den hut schweiz propaganda gemacht damit
sie nach dem krieg wieder brav
zurückkommen denn die schweiz ist ja
eigentlich in englisch erfindung nehmen
18 sekunden nicht eine erste eine von
schiller sondern schon die engländer
haben dass wir haben bei uns entdeckt
und ihr andere bruder der eigentlich der
liebste war war in amerika der arbeitete
bei firestone in acryl und sie hat bis
ins alter hinein auch wenn ich in
england war ich war ja auch an christ
als student hatte englische briefe
geschrieben bis zum letzten augenblick
immer englisch tier war in englisch
gouvernante beirat bei einer arztfamilie
das war diese größte zeit und das
emigrieren und emigration und depression
das ist ihre spannweite und sie konnte
nicht die migrieren
sie ist war gefangen als schulmeister
gattin und dann wirkte und mutter eines
sohns der zum lieben gott werden wollte
jesus eigentlich wie möglich und auch
der ranzen zeigte aber die andere seite
die fahrerseite war die erzähler seite 3
und sie wurden dann auch ein großer
erzähler und einer der größten noch
lebenden schriftsteller und alle diese
biografischen details und zusammenhänge
die werden ganz schön geschildert wie
ich finde in der biografie von manfred
tricks die ich sehr empfehlen kann
da ist stellt sich natürlich die frage
mit so einer kindheit und sie sprechen
jetzt auch immer viel darüber setzen
sich ist ja immer noch damit auseinander
waren der das schreiben die literatur
die kunst auch eine form von von flucht
von von therapie vielleicht für sie
beides
es war ganz sicher zuerst eine flucht
wobei der widerspruch darin bestand dass
derselbe junge mann dann von allem
möglichen extremen träumte ein heimkind
gewesen war gerade unglückliche kinder
sind heimweh kinder als mich die eltern
einen schulkameraden nach beckenried in
die ferien mit namen musste man mich
mein vater nach zwei tagen zurückholen
weil ich zu viel heim werden
das sind so verrückte dinge und derselbe
mensch hat dann als er endlich professor
wenn auch erst am gymnasium an der
oberrealschule wie sie damals hieß
geworden war habe ich beim beim
unterschreiben des vertrags gesagt jeder
zeit kann ich meinen vertrag kündigen
wenn ich irgend etwas wie ein ruf nach
japan gekommen und japan das war die
fahrerseite
das war die tochter meines vaters die
aus erster ehe elsa mit ihrem jahrbuch
hansi und du mir unterwegs ein paar
kinder partners jutta und als von ich
später geträumt habe und danach den fuß
gesetzt das war das spielzeug das ich
lernen musste
das waren zwei spielzeuge seine war
bewegung denn zu hause musste ich
eigentlich us-start leben denn wenn ich
mich bewegte tat sich meine mutter
begegnen also bewegung musste ich lernen
daher habe ich vieles von der
fahrerseite gelernt aber im grunde bin
ich dann doch wieder am zürichsee ein
bisschen weiter oben gelandet nicht im
zolli konzern in männedorf dass mein
vater selber jerusalem am pfannenstiel
genannt hat man ja als dort noch die die
pid ist
herrscht aber japan blieb dann prägen
sie waren danach da in diesem heim wlan
dass sie aus der kindheit kannten aus
diesem kinderbuch ihrer haupt schwester
elsa dass sie erwähnt haben waren in den
60er jahren in japan das erste buch der
ist der roman er spielt in japan und
auch das neueste werk heimkehr nach nach
fukushima spielt wieder da und darf das
japanische denken hat sie sehr stark in
den bann gezogen kann man glaube ich
sagen insbesondere auch dass das setzt
der zen buddhismus und da auch diese
einsicht dass nicht alles schwarz und
weiß ist dass widersprüche gleichzeitig
existieren können diese dieser umgang
mit mit ambivalenzen aber auch einen
sinn für die grenzen der eigenen sprache
sie haben sich ja gerne auch mit musik
beschäftigt mit meister eckhart und in
der doktorarbeit mit ernst barlach was
würden sie sagen ist die wichtigste ein
sich diese gewonnen haben eben
zusammenhang mit dem zen buddhismus
es ist wie mit japan selbst die
wichtigste einsicht ist zugleich die
unerschwinglich sste wenn meine frau
mich verabschieden will
dann nennt sie mich du japan-kenner sie
leben ja mit einer japanerin verheiratet
genau das ist sozusagen das ironische
kompliment par excellence im sprichwort
heißt rheine hat der andere liebt und
japan gehört zu den dingen die ich liebe
aber natürlich durch die brille des
fremd ich glaube auch nicht dass man
ohne sich selbst und zu verleugnen und
die anderen zu belügen authentisch
japanisch sein kann wenn man da nicht
geboren ist und da nicht aufgewachsen
aber der traum davon dass man ihn
dagegen war ganz bei sich selbst sein
kann hier und jetzt diesen traum habe
ich eine weile auch im zen kloster
geträumt und bin natürlich wie bei allen
wunsch für lungen vielen ironien
begegnet nun zb die strenge disziplin
etwa beim essen
man darf mich sich selber einschätzen
dass du nur der anderen also und man
redet nicht und derselbe sender ist da
der mich darauf genommen hat in seiner
strikten klub hat mir als ich ein
bisschen quandt war ist ja irgendwie in
die städtchen gegangen und hat ein stück
torte für mich ein gekauft also eine
reine lizenz eine ganz kindliche ein
kindliches geschenkt um diese art von
wunderbar in konsequenter weise die habe
ich dort kennen gelernten lieben gelernt
ich war mal in einer krise in meinem
jungen erwachsenenalter im
kapuzinerkloster von la paz wie ich dann
als haben sie interesse an solchen
flüchtlingen hat haben sie unterdessen
meinen job gemacht aber damals war ich
wahrscheinlich noch der erste und
einzige und wie märchen klingelte ich
reformiert wie ich war kloster glocke
und wurde eingelassen und nahm dann am
katholischen kloster leben teil so weit
wie möglich
die geschichte dieser geschichte die ich
im kloster der kapuziner die akkus
wieder erlebt habe die vergesse ich
nicht da hat gab es einen menschen einen
bruder der offenbar dafür war dazu
bestimmt waren mich zum katholizismus zu
bekehren oder jedenfalls mit diesem
geschäft beschäftigt war und dann kam
hat er mich ein teil eines tages gerufen
habe ich gedacht aha aufgepasst jetzt
sollst du daran kommen dann hat er mir
gesagt ich habe ein problem vielleicht
können sie mir helfen weil ich gerade
weil sie nicht dazu gehören ich spiele
gitarre und mein oberer meine open
finden ich spiele schlecht spiele ist
aber so gern können sie mir sagen ob ich
so schlecht spielen und das war ein so
herzergreifend moment
ich brachte es nicht übers herz ihm zu
sagen dass es vielleicht spielt da
spielt einfach nicht sehr professionell
und nicht virtuos aber ich bin nach
einer zum opern und hatte dann die
chance im zu sagen sie sollen den mann
doch weiterspielen lassen
da wollte mich nicht bekehren wollte
endlich einen hörer haben
das ist so eine wunderbare religiöse
geschichte eine andere wahl
es gab einen beichtvater einem
nonnenkloster am morgen es existiert
heute noch
und dieser bei vater nahm mich einmal
mit für und sei zu seinem zustand und
das war eine hochgelobte für sache der
waren im grunde wie ein harlems wächter
kam er zu diesen damen die st die neuen
sachen wunderbar eigentlich schon nigro
spirituosen das war damals ich war noch
nie sein ding
trotz 30 oder so und ich wurde
vorgeführt so als als sophies das hat
sie schon mal ein buch geschrieben als
hobbys des klosters kapuzinerklosters
und hatte dann plötzlich diese weibliche
nonnen als fans musterbücher
unterschreiben und das war alles so
unglaublich human und hat dem nichts zu
tun mit dem strikten christentum dass
ich zu hause gelernt unserer kirche
gehöre aber diese beiden dinge gehen
irgendwie zusammen dieses höchste
erhabene göttliche und das menschliche
banale alltägliche und das machen sie
auch wenn sie sagen inkonsequente
weisheit und diese im 10
auch wieder gefunden haben würden sie
sagen das fehlt uns heute in der
heutigen gesellschaft diese ambiguität
solche rolle hans wie man so schön sagt
also dieser sind für widersprüche für
inkonsequenten die kennzahl linken szene
die wir heute haben dass man also bei
bestimmten zeichen die man setzt von
sich gibt abgeschriebene da bist du
draußen aus der gemeinschaft der
zivilisierten das
bei feministischen diskurs rassistischen
diskurs in zweiter ein falsches war und
du hast den stempel
das ist im grunde eine form von
auschwitz man stempel leute ab und von
da an sind sie kommen sie als
gesprächspartner nicht in frage
was ich an diesem praxis entsetzlich
finde ist nicht nicht einmal das
inhumane es ist das interesse lose an
eigenen widersprüchen
das ist doch der ganze spaß des lebens
das ich mich dabei ertappen lernen dass
ich das das miteinander mit einer völlig
unserer ein paar dinge von dem man mir
in der sonntagsschule beigebracht hat
das eine ist bei jesus sein als beim
teufel
dass die zusammengehen dass diese
widersprüche und widersprüche in meinem
kopf oder in der kultur sind aber ich
sollte den teufel tun und diese
widersprüche sozusagen betonieren
zementieren wie wir das heute tun
diese schrecklichen vereinfachung
dahinter ist immer ein ein redlicher
impuls man will leute disqualifizieren
die schwarz ließ qualifizieren das ist
sehr ehrenwert aber diese
disqualifikation gerät ins genau gleiche
faschistoide fan wasser das ausschließen
zu anderen nur sind jetzt andere andere
ja also ich meine die gegenseite würde
natürlich sagen dahinter stecken
jahrhunderte jahrtausende lange
leidensgeschichte
diese schwarzen bevölkerung der frauen
auch und es ist nichts als anständig da
irgendwie hin zu stehen und für für
anstand zu sorgen und die leute auch zur
rechenschaft zu ziehen
es ist interessant sie wurden ja auch
kritisiert vor zehn jahren haben sie im
berliner tagesspiegel
den ehemaligen leiter der odenwaldschule
gerold becker so ein bisschen in schutz
genommen was was die übergriffe in der
odenwaldschule betreffen wurden danach
heftig kritisiert
da ist ja schon die frage ich meine man
kann sagen die leute sind
widersprüchlich man sollte die den täter
vor seiner tat trennen der mensch ist
immer mehr als das und trotzdem muss man
doch auch konsequenzen ziehen wenn sie
diesen artikel nicht mehr schweigen
es war ein impuls von meinen wirklichen
freund helmut n tisch der der
lebensgefährte dieses übeltäter sind da
und odenwaldschule war eine lanze zu
brechen
ich habe das getan am vorabend einer
operation die ernsthaft war das was sich
noch leisten wollte hat man sozusagen
entscheidend ist möglicherweise
endgültigen ich wusste nicht ob ich die
operation über liebe und dann wäre es
mein letztes wort gewesen
für handys stehen ich als seinen nicht
nur weil ihnen jeder mann für den
größten reformpädagogen deutschland
zielt vor der odenwald geschichte
sondern weil ich ihn kenne kennengelernt
habe wir mit ihren umgibt wie er mit
menschen umgeht so nährt von foreman hat
jetzt mal ganz von den von den
erziehungs prinzipien abgesehen und
diesen menschen in dieses schlamassel
gezogen zu sehen war der eigentliche
beweggrund für diesen brief damals dafür
viele leute land so wichtig war dass
ihnen in meinem wikipedia beitrag zu
sagen als letztes wort über mich
gebracht habe
ich hänge nach wie vor als freund mit
diesem hartmut von hentig zusammen er
hatte den mut gehabt seinen freund nicht
zu verleugnen
er hatte die kraft gehabt ihn zu tode zu
pflegen
das sind lauter dinge die für mich wenn
die hexa dann wenn die wenn man unterm
strich sagen wir unterm strich sind das
die menschlichen dinge die wirklich
zählen und dagegen sind die schubladen
in dem man leute versorgt um sie
abzulegen und zu disqualifizieren sind
missbrauch das ist da waren ist es ist
interessant war diese schubladen die
haben natürlich mit unserem denkt mit
unserer sprache zu tun
unsere sprache operiert oft bühne
zwischen gut böse weiß und schwarz ja
und nein
und ihr interesse für zen buddhismus für
ihr aber auch für mystic die sehr früh
schon einsetzt da geht man ja die
grenzen der sprache und dann schweigen
der hg einen schriftsteller
ich würde sagen ihre prämisse würde ich
an fächer die sprache ist kein computer
untertitel sprache unterscheidet
dogmatiker tun es zwischen 0 und 1 gut
und böse heute und morgen zu
unterscheiden
und da die ganze digitale welt lebt ja
von dieser grundlage die sprache schauen
sie eine halbe stunde ihres lebens in
grimms wörterbuch und zu jedem war eine
sagenhaft eine tolle geschichte
entwickelt wird das ist so aber die
logik sagt doch dieses blatt ist
entweder weiß oder es ist nicht weiß und
etwas drittes gibt es nicht das doch mal
bei aristoteles nachlesen ja unter dem
titel ist wäre ja auch nicht nur blut
sehen sie sind und sie stellen sich
jetzt dagegen in der sprache zusammen
das war kein sprache ist so platon war
ein und aber verrückt
die annahme von sokratis das
intelligente wies leute wissen dass sie
nichts wissen oder nicht genug dies mir
lieber die sprache selber ist klug
klüger als die meisten ihrer sprecher
benennen sie den teufel gut sei bei uns
das ist mir jetzt noch mehr eingefangen
also bald als ein beispiel dafür wie man
die ambivalenz die tiefe der
gespaltenheit zwischen dem was bei
menschen unter menschen gut und böse
heißt dass man plötzlich wieder fcn
übeltäter den heiligen entdeckt
diese art von interesse am menschen
finde ich das existenzminimum der
zivilisation und da hat dieses ganze
sparten wesen nichts zu tun und die
ganze ich habe gelernt zu lügen meiner
kindheit ich habe meine mutter über
alles mögliche
nichts für ein u vorgemacht und haben
nicht vergessen dass ich so nur
zweierlei dinge sind aber ich habe
gesehen auch an lebt oder mitgenommen
dass unter bestimmten umständen
menschlich sein kann zu lügen oder allzu
menschen nicht nur und notlügen es war
ein sind immer noch trüben wenn man
nicht offen und war sein kann mit sich
untereinander nicht mann und die meisten
konventionen sind eingefroren flügel mit
diesem sinn
aber wenn ich mir vorstelle jetzt
bekommen wir doch analysis beispiel das
verhältnis jesu zu judas dass ein
haushalt da war sozusagen der manager
und auf eine als geschichtlich hoch
interessante weise auch sein
vertrauensmann denn er hat den berühmten
judaskuss hat er erwidert die beiden
waren in ihrem job des menschheit zu
lösungsweg es begriffen und da eine
hatte den beschissenen teil
unter anderem hatte den auch
beschissenen teil nur dass der nachher
roth wurde zur ewigen seligkeit 'nen zum
der andere hang des judas hat sich
aufgehängt und jesus wurde aufgehängt
kreuzen und ob dann eine auferstehung
gab für den einen eher als für den
andern weiß ich nicht aber ich weiß dass
die ganze spannung zwischen gut und böse
die in von christus selber immer wieder
dementiert wurde also wer von euch ohne
sünde ist werfe den ersten stein auf
eine sogenannte sündige frau
beispielsweise oder warum ist denn
zöllner und den notorischen bescheißen
und beim einzug grenzzäune
man hat da die als sein publikum
angesehen und nicht die pharisäer also
die vorher wussten was gut und böse ist
und die dogmatiker wissen es bis heute
und ich weiß es bis heute nicht und es
ist für sie auch eine essenz ein zeichen
von weisheit mit dieser
widersprüchlichkeit auch leben zu können
und den einzelfall wie sie goethe
zitiert haben immer vor augen zu halten
ich möchte noch etwas in japan bleiben
weil in dem dokumentarfilm über sie
reißen sie auch noch nach japan
und zwar nach fukushima in das
verstrahlte gebiet und sehr
eindrückliche szene ich möchte mit ihnen
damals kurz gemeinsam
wir stehen hier auf dem gesamten boden
fukushimas hier wächst wieder ein
bisschen was nach aber die erste die
hier mal war die dicht hier forums
umgelagert herausgeschafft umgelagert in
ein stück land art jetzt beginnt man zu
sehen dass die japanische kunst der
verpackung wirksam wird
niemand weiß wohin damit welche erde ist
tief genug dass man sich darin vergraben
kann ein land mit erdbeben ganz sicher
nicht
und wenn wir nicht aufpassen werden wir
diese wunderbaren sack kärnten bei uns
bald auch haben uns auch nicht wissen
wohin damit
[Musik]
ja sehr eindrücklich sie sagen die
japanische kunst der verpackung ist das
nicht nur ein euphemismus ein schönes
wort für verdrängung auch aber nicht nur
dass wieder einer der fälle wo man eben
die dinge nicht nach schwarz und weiß
unterscheidet die verpackung ist enthält
ja zwei ausdruck von liebe das objekt
des geschenks das so packte ist das
weniger wichtige aber der respekt vor
dem den mann damit beschenkt ist der
größere und was man ihm mit einem
verpackung positiven sinne antut das ist
das wahre geschenkt und natürlich ist
zusammen überlegt also ich habe zum
beispiel in japan gelernt dass man nie
ein nein hören wird von einem fremden
von daher gegenüber fremden also wenn
einen japaner ein so etwas wie nein sagt
es gibt kein wort dafür eigentlich dann
ist entweder der todfeind oder beste
freund dem vorjahr sind die sicherungen
zu groß also die soziale es ist genau
dasselbe bei mechanismus masken tragen
bei pandemie ist für japan eine solche
selbstverständlichkeit weil jedes kind
wenn es den schnupfen hat schon im jahre
mit diesem mit dieser maske in die
schule gekommen ist nicht weil es diese
maske tragen will sondern weil es die
anderen schützen will
darum ist für meine frau zum beispiel
die stolze weigerung freier westler sich
nicht impfen zu lassen und können keine
maske zu tragen eine schlichte
unverschämtheit gedankenlos bis hinten
raus und asozial
das wären wir sagen dass ich seine
beschränkt meiner freiheitsrechte wir
können jetzt dank das glas im gesicht zu
gesicht
aber sobald das glas weg
ist nehmen so die maske vor und die
maske ist für uns sozusagen ein schlag
ins gesicht des individuums und für
japan nur dieses eine sache elementaren
höflichkeit auch ohne pandemie also das
war nur ein beispiel wie anders es doch
jetzt ist eine andere form der
höflichkeit der diskretion auch und es
gibt ja auch die zeit diagnose dass
heute ein charme verlust herrscht oder
richard sennett hat von einer tyrannei
der öffentlichkeit gesprochen schon
früher sind sie da auch ein punkt dass
wir etwas von der japanischen kultur
lernen können in sachen höflichkeit
diskretion förmlichkeit sie machen es
mir schwer weil ich wenn ich ja sage
muss ich ja meine eigene neigung zu
offenen rebellionen verleugnen und was
ich heute sehe in japan aber ich sehe es
mit der mit den augen des fernsehen
betrachters was ich heute sehe seine
regierung die sich um jeden preis und um
hohe preise drückt und der anerkennung
dessen was man für das land bedeutet bei
das schlimmste für die japaner ist dann
darüber reden dann jemanden belasten
müssen dann anfangen zu rechnen wer hat
welchen schadensersatz zu leisten
man nehme an kein ende und dann herrscht
diskretion ich erinnere mich an eine für
mich in europa oder amerika vollkommen
undenkbar geschichte als der als dieser
abbau lief schnell als der atoss die
kernschmelze lief da gab es immer
denselben namen und tropft entsprechende
regierungssprecher damit deine musste
was jetzt wieder läuft versagen ist ja
auch seit fiel in der schweiz am
fernseher und da hat es immer beschönigt
natürlich als wollten den leuten nicht
zumuten jetzt
es ging ja darum kann hat der damalige
regierungschef hat dann die evokation
tokios gedacht was physisch unmöglich
geworden wäre aber nötig wenn man wenn
das zweite dann daheim das zweite
gleiche
kraftwerk auch geschmolzen wäre
und da hat diese arme mann also jeden
tag eine schreckliche nachricht zu
verkünden gehabt dann wissen sie die
reaktion des publikums darauf war der
arme mann er hat so viel zu mitzuteilen
das sollte wieder einmal ausschlafen
dann sage ich nur chapeau und zu gott
beides im gleichen atemzug das ist jetzt
lassen die japaner im wasser ihr
kühlwasser in die in den ozeanen
das haben wir heute gelesen zum großen
protest fischer die man fast die fast
heilige geworden sind im versuch
irgendwo gute fischer zu es ist ja
interessant
all das spricht dagegen das heiligtum
was wir heutzutage hoch halten die
transparenz wir sind eine gesellschaft
der transparenz geworden das sagen nach
bekannten philosophen etwa 40 hahn zum
beispiel würden sie dann sagen ein stück
verdrängung ein stück geheimnis gehört
zu einem guten leben immer auch dazu
nein ich würde sagen es gehört
anerkennung dazu dass wir in uns selber
bietet sportliche wiesen sieht das hat
nichts mit bezeichnung zu tun
ich bin ich habe eine psychoanalyse
gemacht bei dem unvergesslichen paul
paris mehrere junge akademiker und da
habe ich etwas gelernt
leider nicht das was ich erwartet ich
kann natürlich unter dem berühmten likes
druck und der berühmte leidensdruck
genuss nicht den respekt ist abenteuers
paris sondern ging davon aus da kommt
eine zu ihm da schreibt also hat das
interesse an seinen eigenen
widersprüchen und das interesse ist
wichtiger als das bisschen leiden daran
dass das auch klar dass man dann leidet
er hat meine abenteuerlust übersetzt
überschätzt und das gespräch mit ihm war
für mich auf eine so fatalerweise
weiße leere ich dass ich in einem meiner
bücher habe ich ein meine figur auf ihn
schießen lassen auf einem psychologen
ist das krone albis grund aber
rückblickend habe ich einen solchen
respekt vor diesem mann weil er so zu
einem wie ein gentleman oder in
englischen ort sagt dass dreck ist
selbstverständlich aber was man daraus
macht
und er hat er war ein abenteuerlustiger
mensch und die psychoanalyse war für ihn
eine erkundung in afrika war ja auch ein
typischer afrika decker und wer dieses
diese neugier nicht hat ist eigentlich
soll seine zeit nicht verschwenden wir
haben ganz am anfang des gesprächs über
das gute leben gesprochen über das was
lebenskunst bedeuten könnte
jetzt gibt es von theodor w adorno dem
berühmten philosophen den schönen satz
es gibt kein richtiges leben im falschen
kein einfacher satz würden sie ihm
zustimmen
das zu einem gelungenen persönlichen
leben immer auch eine gerechte
gesellschaft gehört weil ich das mal so
glaubt übersetzen darf für den ergänzen
es gibt im sogenannten falschen leben so
viele spuren des richtigen sozusagen
glanzpunkte des richtigen die sogar im
unaufgeklärten und primitiven kontext
möglich sind herzlichkeit gastlichkeit
interesse für den anderen da mag der
rahmen noch so falsch sein das ist auch
unter einer tyrannei möglich und oft
gerade dort möglich gewesen also die was
die asien reisenden an der
gastfreundschaft der afghanen zum
beispiel zu räumen hatten vor 45 100
jahren
das hat sagt sie das finden wir nicht im
westen
das haben wir verloren und es gibt ein
es gibt richtiges leben im falschen
darauf
gerade der begriff des falschen den wir
entwickeln können wir sehen sozusagen
zugunsten dessen was wir richtig als
richtig empfinden und als notwendig
sehen wir das falsch an unserer
gesellschaft und das war ja auch kein
glaubenssatz kann war jan dialektiker
und wieder bricht zusammen ein kind sagt
soll ich französisch lernen soll ich
eigentlich lernt weiter und sagen wozu
sagte dass das tool das einstein nicht
schlecht kann zu hohen französisch lernt
dann am schluss also alles wird
sozusagen durch getan was das gehen
fragt soll ich das lernen müssen sagt ja
mein kind lampen französische dort
schlange was immer und dieser art
widerspruch den müssen wir aushalten und
das ist viel schwieriger
vor allem ist es aber auch viel lustiger
es ist doch spannend dass wir monströs
gegensätzlicher wesen sind und das
gegenteil dessen tun wozu behaupten ist
normal werden wir das mal angesehen hat
und umgekehrt
der hat auch ein spaß am leben wieder
haben sie gebraucht bis sie das
eingesehen haben lange
natürlich bin ich auch dann stolz auf
seiner ansicht aber ich bin immer noch
darin kindlich dass ich funde zeigen
und jeder von uns geht mit dem wasser
zum fund gef und gewinn gefunden zu
haben glaubt geht er gerne hausieren und
darauf beruhend die die ruhmesblatt eine
sogenannten engagierten eine sogenannte
bund und und dichters ne das war
zeitlebens ein engagierter
intellektueller
sie haben sogar an der präambel der
schweizerischen bundesverfassung
mitgeschrieben sie haben das ständerat
kandidiert und gleichzeitig ist die ist
die svp im stande die behandelt so
schlecht dass wir schnell wieder mit
blocher haben sie sich auch zahlreiche
verstritten indem sie die rolle der
schweiz im 2
kritisierten usw zum schluss vielleicht
noch eine persönliche frage des heims
versöhnlich genug mehr eine richtung
persönlich die sie zitieren gerne
heinrich von klar ist der mal gesagt hat
wenn man die eigenen kinder ermahnt dann
wären die vor allem eines nämlich
ermahnen dem zylinder frau natürlich die
frage jetzt ja selbst haben drei söhne
welche lektionen in lebenskunst glauben
sie haben sie diesen söhnen vorgelebt
vorleben können bis heute leider keine
ich habe im grunde mein mein eigenes kam
als kind einer depressiven mutter und
eines verstorbenen vaters habe ich meine
söhne weitergegeben
ich bin mit allen nie lange genug
zusammen gewesen sie sich dann ihren
verschiedenen ehen also an meiner
wankelmütigkeit an meinem versuchung des
versuchs bedürfnis ich bin mit keinem
lange genug zusammen gewesen um ihnen
etwas was an mir liegt mit zu geben was
sie bekommen haben muss an ihnen liegen
dass unsere verhältnis gut ist mit allen
dreien das ist ihr verdienst denn sie
hatten keinen vater auf den sie sich
verlassen konnten
und darum bin ich ein liebhaber meine
söhne
ich habe sie sehr gerne das was sie mir
vor leben ist ein geschenk das sie
könnten genauso gut solche komplexen wie
ich das nehme ich gerne als schlusswort
und ihre söhne haben ja auch ihre bücher
müssen sie sich die sie müssen sich
nicht lesen und diversen sie
wahrscheinlich gelesen haben helmut wir
sind leider schon am ende des gesprächs
auch die zeit hat ihre grenzen oder
unsere sendung hat grenzen das ist wie
ich gelernt habe auch ganz gut so und
auch widersprüche wahrscheinlich wird
man finden können vielen herzlichen dank
ich danke ihnen sehr
[Musik]